and I'm going to start with attendances
and I've had apologies from councilor
Maitland councilor Bennett and councilor
Hornby
um I don't know if any more that you're
aware of Alex I also received apologies
from counteracting and Council Burton
okay
thank you
and are there any Declarations of
interest
um many members in any of the items here
no
um we've received the minutes
um
a bit late in the day but has anybody
had a chance to look at them and are we
happy that they are a true record
I'm sure they will be okay I'm not aware
of any questions from the public
good
okay so we go on to my my favorite item
of the year
um it's presentations from the students
from Trafford College
um which is in my ward I live just
around the corner from you so I probably
uh seen you on and off getting off the
tram if you come down to uh broad Heath
there
um so I've got on my list and I hope
I've got Anne Laura Mary Sam
chamber Frank and Rabia
Frank didn't make it okay no problem so
thank you all
for coming
um shall we introduce ourselves and then
you you introduce yourselves yeah so
Alex who's running the show at the end
there he's our Democratic Services
officer
um and he's there to keep me in order in
case I do anything wrong okay I'm going
to start with um Council of Proctor John
to introduce yourself
unless
[Music]
I start again so I'm counselor Shirley
Proctor but you call me Shirley unless
I'm in trouble because I don't need to
be called counselor okay
um my award is Debut meast which covers
an area between the Trafford Center and
halfway to urmston
and it's got a little bit traffic Park
in it and it's
um got all sorts of different houses so
all sorts of different people who live
there and it's great
[Music]
hi yeah um I'm Catherine Heinz so I'm
the deputy leader of the council
um and I am the executive member for
children's services so I'm not actually
a member of this committee but I come to
this committee because people of this
committee scrutinize some of the
decisions that I make so that's um that
that's why I'm here but I'm responsible
really for all the children and young
people in Trafford so it's really good
to see you
hiya my name's Adele new I'm a counselor
for buckler Ward which is Partington
Carrington and sail west I'm here this
evening because I'm also lead member for
education
thank you
hiya my name's Amy y I'm a counselor in
Broadview Ford same as Denise and I'm a
member of the committee thank you
hello I'm Linda Blackburn
um I'm a counselor in Village ward in
timperley
um and um the deputy Chen of this
committee by Shannon I should say and uh
about 25 years ago I was teaching at
Trafford College when it was South
Trafford College I did the the the post
um special needs students so that's a
another lifetime ago and lonely to see
you
I'm going to ask our officers I'm Denise
by the way I chair the committee at the
moment
um I'm going to ask our officers to
introduce themselves to you as well
hi yeah I'm Pamela Walton
um from early help and children social
care
hi good evening my name is Glenn
Perryman I'm head of Provider Services
here at traffic Council nice to meet you
hi everyone I'm Jill McGregor I'm the
corporate director for children's
services so that means the the services
and the the things that are going to be
scrutinized today set under my portfolio
hi everyone I'm Karen samples Director
of Education in Trafford
um teacher by trade so passionate about
young people and teaching and learning
so it's it's going to be great to to
hear you tonight thank you
do you want to carry on young lady
hello I'm Toby and I'm reading the
speech on behalf of Frank today
hi my name is Laura and I study um
illegal biology chemistry and math in
travel college and I'm a student leader
and a member of the equalities Council
hi my name is Sam I study law and
business in Trafford college first year
and I'm here today to talk about social
Mobility with Rabia
hi my name is
I do sociology law politics and Italian
foreignty thank you
good evening I am Shay malakal I study
at shopwood College chemistry biology
and psychology and I will be talking
about developing skills today
foreign
hi my name is Marianne O'Reilly I'm a
level three business and law student and
I'm a member of the equalities Council
green College assembly mental health and
wellbeing Champions and I'm a course
representative
hello everyone good evening thank you
for having us my name is Anne Fernandes
I am the member of the equalities
Council as well as the deputy climate
Champion for the planet Earth games
that's super thank you so much a wide um
range of different subjects that you're
all studying so I'm sure you're going to
put me to shame with your knowledge of
everything
um so I understand that you're going to
be talking to us about following on from
the mind the skills Gap campaign today
and you're going to be highlighting
towards the value of further education
which is something I'm sure we all
believe strongly in in this room so Anna
you're going to start yes I am okay soon
good evening everyone
um as we mentioned before we are
students of the Trafford college group
equalities Council and today we are here
to talk about the Mindless skills Gap
campaign
the equalities Council now is the
campaign group here in college where we
express our opinions real great to cause
we have things such as The Debate Club
the student newsletter and we do charity
drives last year we did a drive for
registering to vote
having an equalities council is a great
part of our College where we can express
how we feel to all the students engage
and bring together a community
we are here today to discuss the various
aspects involved in the minor skills Gap
campaign and the data that we have
collected
let me brief you on about what it's all
about the minor skills Gap campaign is
aimed towards more funding for colleges
and post-16 education which provides
necessary skills for students as it is
colleges that fills in this gaps that we
require when looking for jobs in various
workforces although colleges are ready
to provide these skills they struggle
with the lack of funding in terms of
hiring staff getting high quality
Equipment and resources which I believe
is important for the development of any
student in any field
thus making it hard for most people to
go into further education
the three priorities in this campaign is
to provide a national strategy
supporting local inclusive growth in the
further education sector
um a right to lifelong learning free
from restrictive constraints as I
mentioned earlier equipment stuffing
work experience and accessibility in
most courses
which will result in Fair and effective
funding
we cannot stress how important this
funding is which is why we have the
campaign
and how important it is on our growing
economy it needs a consistent constant
ongoing investment in skills especially
for jobs today since workplaces require
the agility and the need for a variety
of skills to be able to keep up with the
ever-changing world and the plethora of
tasks that come with it
sadly as we know this investment is not
happening in the post-system education
and it's way behind and it's due to this
we do not we cannot boost our economic
growth which is hampering
in the growth that we require
investment in skills yields both
immediate and long-term benefits through
increased production assisting
businesses in finding and developing
productive employees and resulting in
Greater salaries which we all like
without additional investment in further
education the skills will there will be
a shortages in these skills
further education to my friends and I
mean the ability to go to university and
to get jobs in the sectors that we want
to do for as you mentioned earlier we're
all doing very broad very different
things and without the ability to
experience what if we really want to do
this and without the ability to develop
ourselves especially standing here
sitting here today we are developing our
skills and speaking to you guys creating
experiences so when we go to work for a
company we have a lot of things to bring
onto the table and we will be able to
benefit the company and ourselves in our
futures further education to us is
valuable to those that see it as one as
we all did today it helps us improve our
craft exercise our minds and expand our
Horizons
as I mentioned earlier we thank you
again so much for giving us this
opportunity to come and speak to you all
thank you so much
um we're going to ameria you're going to
do the next
little bit
[Music]
further education reaches more than one
million young people in the UK each year
who study a wide variety of courses and
will be trained to fill the gaps in our
labor markets such as Healthcare
engineering construction and even
teachers
the number of students attending further
education has risen by 4.3 percent from
the previous Academic Year but this has
not been reflected in the funding unlike
schools and universities who saw an
increased funding in the Autumn
statement
Trafford college alone has
3635 students across the Stratford and
Altrincham campuses with 200 with 2
675 of these students being aged between
16 and 19 and they are the students of
our future without the correct funding
these students will not have the same
level of Education as our predecessors
79 of these students will move on to
higher education apprenticeships or
directly to employment and further
education provides the nation with the
skills for our future Workforce so we
ask that you join our campaign
and to highlight the value of further
educations and ask for parity of esteem
and fairness with schools and
universities
further education is also important for
further down the line as many people use
further education to transition careers
as they may need to do so in order to
fill these gaps that we cannot just yet
at 16 years old we are forced to choose
which skills to develop with mandatory
further education until we are 18.
for some perspective
857 students at Trafford College are
adults these 857 people have found that
they need something that they do not
have and further education has to fill
that Gap
it also provides a unique flexibility
that allows for people to choose where
they want to go and allows for mistakes
to happen
for this I can only draw from my own
personal experience
I started college directly after covid
completely unprepared and meaning that
six months down the line I didn't know
what I wanted to do and I was incred I
was struggling incredibly with the
amount of work that I was forced to
endure
this meant that I changed to an
apprenticeship in child care which
didn't work for me
this helped me understand the value of
the education I was receiving at College
because I wasn't prepared to enter the
workforce just yet
when I realized that my skills were
better suited to law which is what I
have chosen to do and Contin and will
continue to do from next year onwards
I was allowed the I was allowed the
ability to change back to
um
college education
the skills that I needed back then are
skills that I am still developing and
will continue to develop but without
these skills and the adequate funding to
develop them our future is in jeopardy
to
shame yes
okay so in our local area we have a
short supply in various skills such as
social workers electrical engineers
programmers software development I.T
business analysts and graphic designers
and many more thankfully further
education is playing a vital role in
competing the current and future skills
shortage in our local area we offer all
types of courses for students regarding
all types of interest and subjects for
example we have shortage in social
workers as I mentioned before and we
offer Health and Social care courses
there are many other examples all the
industries were were skill shortages are
being felt most accurately are serviced
by level three skills and qualifications
which are delivered in the further
further education colleges
um these are practical skills that are
taught to a very high standards to
ensure job Readiness and job
Effectiveness
additionally our colleges have qualified
teachers who teach in demand skills
um to an industry standard we also try
to offer smaller than average class
sizes so that this will increase the
amount of direct teaching and access
access to specialized equipment leading
to better outcomes
colleges try to tend to recruit from the
local area and offer more supportive
learning environment which means
Learners get what they need when they
need it and are more likely to graduate
all of this leads to a rich educational
social experience that helps us Learners
to develop the essentials the essential
people skills needed in the fast
changing world of work
unfortunately breakfast had had a
significant impact in our skill Supply
which led to a shortfall of over 330
000 people in the UK labor force mostly
in the low-skilled economy
another factor that affected skill
shortage is covid-19 due to the pandemic
many people lost their jobs
but the types of jobs emerging from the
crisis are now very different from the
ones that um have been lost uh leaving a
gap between the new skills required and
those that exist already
software business analyst operations
management business engineer graphic
designers Architects are all professions
that will be in need in the next five to
ten to twenty years which very
interestingly are the same that are in
shortage right now which means by
investing in the further education right
now we're actually solving two problems
in one
from personal experience college played
an essential role in developing
important skills for example I'm
personally willing to apply for medicine
in order to become a surgeon and
Trafford college is providing me with a
level course
uh in the subjects that I mentioned
before and
um also as well as essential skills
um such as working in a team staying
organized being able to hold to handle
big projects such as this one
um and especially with my communication
skills and it also has helped me with
critical and constructive thinking
um
in general the purpose of this campaign
is to highlight the importance of the
further education to be in the same
level as schools and universities in
terms of funding because without this
additional investments in further
education and skills we will not be able
to feel these skill shortages and in key
priority areas of the economy and
deliver the labor market that our local
area is most in need of
thank you let me see rabbiette next yeah
social Mobility how does further
education increase young people's social
Mobility
further education is a crucial part of a
Young Person's path to achieve a greater
status than the one they were born with
is supplements social mobility in the
most efficient way
possible providing young people young
people with the skills required to
progress into the future skills like
organization problem solving teamwork
and even emotional intelligence it
allows young people to grow and progress
with their peers which is fundamental
for improving their social skills and
allowing them to gain confidence whether
it's a levels or b-techs further
education is fundamentally what allows
young people to truly find what people
really want to do in life
[Music]
um yep so research from several studies
found that lifetime benefits from the
accusation of courses at level two and
three are significant between the
various qualifications of learning or
significant financial returns associated
with the range of further education
qualifications at level two uh stand
between 11 000 pounds to 23 000 pounds
for men and between 21
000 to 43 000 for women compared to the
possession of the next highest level of
qualification which is level three like
a levels and level three B techs that
offer higher wages between 35
000 and 53 000 pounds so
um how has the federal education helped
me in life I'm going to talk about that
now I've personally gained many benefits
and opportunities from completing My
Level 2 courses Like My GCSE English and
GCSE history
uh for example the English GCSE level 2
allowed me to build up my writing and
reading skills since English wasn't my
first language it's my second language
so you know this level 2 course helped
me to get through college and to proceed
to a level three course and my next
level two course was the GCSE history
which taught me the history of the world
and also educated me to be able to
discuss crucial past events in wellverse
manners and I also feel more a knowledge
about British history
thinking
some and we're going back and forth okay
yeah
so
um further education provides young
people with the
um from disadvantaged backgrounds with
opportunities how does this improve the
social Mobility
as mentioned previously the skills
gained through further education
programs are innumerable and
long-lasting arguably some students may
come from
um that come from Advanced backgrounds
maybe taught skills from a young age and
may therefore enter
further education courses with an edge
that other students may not possess
despite this it's safe to say that by
the end of these courses most people
leave with the same amount of skills and
proficiencies as everybody as everybody
else no matter their background
so we need to realize that people take
these qualifications not just for the
economic ends but because they want to
be a part of something that they want to
find or rebuild uh
their confidence in to achieve something
and to see if this is something they may
have an interest for or might enjoy
that's removing funding affected further
education further education could see
um no they're from their phones could
see funding removed from up to 85
percent of level two and Below
qualifications rising to 90 of
qualifications for young people
inevitably the size of freeform means
qualifications with with equal value are
in danger of being scrapped this means
that teenagers will be a big
disadvantage all around the country for
not being able to proceed down to the
career path that they want to proceed in
or that they have interest in uh even
gain opportunities to be able to advance
into better paying jobs
we ensure that this we must ensure that
this must this doesn't happen young
people should be able to advance into
their careers of their choosing with the
same level of support that people from
more advantaged households get everybody
deserves an equal chance at life
thank you thank you and uh moving on to
Laura yeah
further education helps develop and
guide individuals to build upon their
existing skills and provide them with
the platform to learn new skills with
extra with lots of extracurricular
opportunities and activities further
education provides individuals to also
develop various skills like
self-confidence and self-esteem the
ability for them to learn on their own
without um the help of their teachers
but with the activities that they in
they engage themselves with I personally
from a child have been eager to be a
medical doctor specifically to be a
surgeon and moving countries at the age
of 16 was quite a strong struck and
struggle for me and that is the age
where you have to be on ground to be a
doctor I was work sorry I was worried
about my education and how and and how
the move will affect me but luckily I
enrolled to Trafford College to study my
gcses as I couldn't go back to high
school now this was an advantage for me
as I was exposed to various activities
that I could participate in to not just
help out the college but to develop
various skills that could help me in the
future being part of the equalities
Council I'm able to raise my voice as a
student via writing in the student
newsletter by raising awareness of
various things even if it's as little as
writing a small section of few studies
tips for students I was able to develop
my creative side and volunteering I am
at school various school events has
helped me to develop my communication
skills and how to approach and address
people now doing my a levels I have been
promoted to being a student leader
and I see this as an opportunity for me
to be a leader for a lot of people that
I don't personally know but being able
to address student issues
um that they face in college with the
principal and with the board
that is like being their voice I'm able
to not only develop my communication
skill but the ability to be a problem
solver and gain more confidence and to
be accountable being part of the event
planning team of the college I'm able to
develop working in the team and being
able to share my ideas to be and to be
Innovative which is a skill needed to be
able to be a successful doctor
alongside being enrolled in the course
and learning about the course in a
further education institution further
education also gives the one the
opportunity to expand various things we
have the opportunity to join various
activities just like the ones I
mentioned but others like The Debate
Club the green College assembly and the
opportunity to be in the sports team be
basketball football or volleyball
the college works with partners and
companies who run workshops on creative
writing
um who run workshops for students to
help develop their skills for example
directing Squad who runs and workshops
on creative writing in the college helps
students to develop their creative
skills and their Innovative skills now
the success who recently did a workshop
about waste in Greater Manchester all
these great opportunities are given to
are provided in further education taking
part in all these activities in the
college and provide the college has
provided me has helped me huge not only
in for my career path but also in my
personal life thank you thanks Laura and
visit Toby
disability sorry thank you
the chance to start my educational path
again is incredible the chance of having
the opportunity to reach for my goals is
incredible
the goal of being a barrister to have
the dream to get into the role that is
highly and competitive and will not be
easy
however with learning and building the
correct skills are in a way will better
my chance of reaching my goals
at the moment I'm studying GCSE maths
psychology and religious studies in
attempt to go to my next stepping stone
on the journey to University
to then becoming where I want to in my
career life
in addition to having an opportunity to
reject these important subjects with
thanks to the college I've learned the
world of debating skills learning to
talk with a crowd confidently and
organizing events
so what are the skills in a that a
barrister needs
um like the ability to communicate with
the a wide range of people and research
and analyze thinking logically on your
feet and the ability to work as a team
of others
as a mature student I know it is going
to be tough to get into the university I
decided the most
and if it weren't for the opportunities
that the college has offered me I
wouldn't be as confident I would get in
for example the chance to lead and
organize across five campuses are
Christmas charity fundraiser while
reading this I develop on my ability to
talk with multiple new people making
carefully thought through tough
decisions and manage a team of
volunteers to make sure it was lead to
success
due to having this opportunity my team
managed to raise over 150 dollars at 150
pounds which is we would not have been
raised if the student experience wasn't
kind enough to offer the chance of this
being part of the debate team planning
working as a team working and talking
strategies and talking confidently In
Crowd of a crowd of people has already
helped me to build the skills I need in
the future in a courtroom
with all this in mind can you imagine if
your offered these opportunities what it
would be have leads for you
the chance not to be equipped with
skills that hasn't been always been
available
to becoming more desirable to potential
university university
apply applicants to job employment
now of course I'm talking from the
skills that I have far less from
extracurricular activities
there are also societies like the lgbtq
community green College assembly and
fitness club
the chance to write for the student's
newspaper and be proud to be a student
ambassador
with the opportunities that have been
kindly offered to me by the college
I've learned and continuously built on
important skills that make an applicant
more desirable despite whether it's
University or job role
its headshot that everyone should have
always been offered
so now I can pass them through
fasten both these books and help
encourage my desirable future University
that I will be the best lawyer if this
place has ever been
well you've blown me away I think we
should give them all a round of applause
absolutely fantastic
um to you're an inspiration you really
are all all of you
um does anybody have any questions
they'd like to ask our students
wow I'm absolutely blown away as well
and I think you could all give all of us
a run for our money actually I can see
you've got incredibly Bright Futures
ahead of you and I'm really really
pleased to hear about the opportunities
that you've had
um through Trafford College I do think
it is an excellent college and perhaps I
should have declared an interest at the
beginning and when we were asked to
declare an interest because I went to
Trafford College myself
um many many years ago I think it's an
entirely different building now
um and my son went to Trafford college
so he finished uh last year and he's at
Lancaster University and he had a
fabulous time at Trafford
um and I think it served in very very
well actually learned he learned a lot
there I was really inspired I think by
what you were talking about in terms of
further education and I think it's
something that
um do doesn't get the focus that it
should and what you have been talking
about it really struck me that I think
that's the case I think we focus a lot
on on schools and and younger
um children and then we focus on kind of
perhaps University or or where people go
off into the careers but we don't focus
on that really critical part and without
that you can't go on
um into the state in into the the areas
that that you want to and progress into
and you talked about there being that um
skills funding Gap
um and I think you probably are because
you've also clued up probably know a lot
about where funding comes from and a lot
of the the funding for Education comes
from central government and I just
wondered if you had any sort of
um any ideas and advice for for us in
terms of how we might potentially Lobby
central government ask central
government for for more funding to where
raise that awareness that you've raised
with us do you have any sort of tips and
ideas for us at all
hi uh so I was going to say uh maybe one
ways to show the statistics on the jobs
that are being created if more people
are doing level twos level threes doing
education becoming lawyers becoming
doctors becoming whatever they want to
do in their career there's more jobs and
they could maybe become CEOs create
companies again more jobs create jobs
that aren't even created yet bring new
ideas to the table
um
I think this is the best way to show
them I mean they are after money so we
could show them
look there's people with ideas there's
people who want to do this there's
people who want to achieve something so
they just need the
education for it you give them the
education and they're gonna give you the
create the jobs create the money the
economy it's just all gonna go in a
circle you know
Delta do have a question and hi yeah I
did have a question which uh Kath sort
of partly stole it's all right no it's
fine I just really wanted to say first
of all I was completely blown away by
your aspiration it's so fantastic for us
to sit here and to listen to Young
people who are literally just over
brimming with enthusiasm and confidence
and the love of learning it's brilliant
so possibly would you be able to help me
with with something I come across a lot
of young people who live in Partington
who through
um things sort of they're out of their
control they don't have a lot of
confidence in themselves they don't
think that they are good enough to go on
to further education and because they
haven't applied themselves at school
they then feel that the results they've
had from school back up the fact that
they they can't aspire to anything so
how would you help me to encourage them
to go on to further education
thank you
um I have a little bit of experience
with this as I've seen this myself in my
own family and I think that first of all
it's important to highlight the fact
that people will make mistakes and
especially young people where nobody is
perfect and as children we still don't
understand
how our current actions will impact our
future and as you said a lot of things
are very much out of our control
and I think that we need to show young
people in that position that it doesn't
mean the end
for example I actually failed the law
portion of my course and yet next year I
will I've been accepted to universities
in order to study law as a degree and I
think that it's important to highlight
these facts because people don't
understand that the end of one road is
just the beginning of another two
doorways can lead into the same room
just because you might choose a left
over the right doesn't mean that it's
the wrong choice
excellent thank you very much for that
maybe bringing in some people who have
been in the same situation as other
teenagers maybe they didn't know what to
do maybe they didn't want to go after
education or didn't feel comfortable but
they got onto the track and became
successful or got to a point where
they're comfortable and they achieved
something maybe if you get a group of
these people and put like a community
project for some teenagers to come in
sit down listen to them talk and give
their life story to them that would
Inspire them because our College
recently for Law and business we got
speakers coming in talking about how
they open their businesses how they
started off and after their speech most
students were like I want to do this I'm
inspired by this I love what how they
went from this point to this point so
one of the speakers was a lady who went
from working in accountancy for banks
all the way up to owning your own CEO
and that just inspired all students to
follow the same path you know stick to
what they're doing and not to like Drop
it which is why it's important to get
people who actually have gone through
the same path have experienced the same
things because if you just want a couple
of teachers to talk to you yes they
might understand you but they might not
have the struggles that you are having
right now but if you get people who have
had who have experienced those struggles
they're going to understand what you're
talking about they're going to know how
you're feeling they're going to know
what to say to you they're going to know
how to encourage you so best thing in my
opinion Community project of speakers
joining up students teenagers sitting
down listening to them and talking to
them having Maybe one-on-ones
yep that's absolutely brilliant thank
you and I'm very fortunate I do have the
opportunity to do that because I work at
a local youth club so that's absolutely
brilliant and I'll actually put that
into motion maybe approach yourself for
some help with that thank you fantastic
Michael did you have a question yes
thank you um thank you for all for
coming down I apologize for for being
late I was in a meeting about trying to
get solar panels on local schools around
here so hopefully that's something
positive uh for the future
um but yeah we hear a lot about the cost
of living crisis we hear it's very hard
for young people to get started uh you
know in the in the current economy that
we have the rents are very high it's
hard to buy a house and that kind of
thing I I was wondering when you talk to
your your peer group you know your
friends other students you know to what
extent is is that influencing the
choices that people are making in terms
of what they study you know whether they
choose practical subjects art subjects
you know where they study and also
whether they you know want to stay
around in our local area because we know
in South Trafford in particular there's
you know we have real cost of living
issues
um you know I'd really be interested to
hear you know what you what your
thoughts on are on those issues
um I love my friends including myself
um I'm this I'm thinking about careers
that are more that are gonna guarantee
me more money because of this issue and
because I come from an ethnic minority
background it's like one of my main
goals to go to school that I need to
earn like much more than my parents are
currently earning and I in fact wanted
to do archeology for University but I've
changed that too low and I think in
terms it's the same with all my friends
um it's a serious issue I think because
if we all become if we all go for that
then we're going to lose our own
interests in life we're gonna lose
ourselves in a way
um yeah
thank you
platform so regarding your question of
who we speak to like colleagues or peers
and get ideas from them me personally at
first I didn't know what I wanted to do
uh my gcc's uh were around the corona
time so I got predicted grades didn't
like them so I came to traffic College
to reset My GCSE reset them then I
didn't know which path I wanted to go
down and I was thinking maybe
architecture because my art was really
good but I was like that's not for me
because I'm like always double-sided
about it so I went in and spoke to a
teacher called Alex Pete he's actually a
solicitor and I told him you know I'm
interested in law could you tell me more
about it and he sat down with me and
fully went through it and just inspired
me and got me to really see like this is
what I want to go into you know this is
what I have interest in and not just for
like that say you want to do it for the
money or for the people just because
like I enjoy doing it you know it's
something that I want to do and that's
like an example of like me talking to
someone in college and them like opening
my mind to like where I want to go
because I had no clue what I wanted to
do and then after speaking to him
um I started the law and Business course
and so far I've been enjoying it and
after I finished this course I'm
planning on it solicitor's
apprenticeship uh and hopefully just
going down the solicitors path but again
I wouldn't be here if it wasn't for him
I I mean maybe I would but he was a big
part in this because he inspired me uh
where I was like I didn't have anybody
else who inspired me to go down this
path
thank you
[Music]
it wasn't a question I just just wanted
to comment
um I love your passion and it's great to
see sorry about that Sam it's great to
see so many young women here and
expressing the views about the the plan
that they've got it doesn't matter who
you are
or which kind of family come from it's
where where you're going to end up and
sometimes in your life you make a plan
and then sometimes you have to do a bit
of a detour maybe to get back on track
or maybe you go on a completely
different routes further on and it's all
going to be dependent on
um on your life experiences and and and
and how you find moving on as as you you
know you want to educate yourself
um but it's it's fabulous to see and
don't don't become despondent if at
first things don't happen for you you
know you've got to you've got to
continue to believe in yourself
and and and be role models for others
and once you get it's you know a certain
way
use use your your knowledge and your
life experiences to Mentor other people
um even The Summer's a mum
but it's you know it's really it's
really important to to reach out to
others and be supportive of others who
you know might need your you know your
experience and and your help and you
know I I really hope that that you
achieve what you want to but be happy
don't just do something because it's
maybe the thing to do because you've got
to enjoy what you do through throughout
your life and some of you might have
more than one career in your life
but it's been great hearing from you and
good luck good luck
so I expect to see at least one of you
in the council chamber
we need young counselors
I'm not the oldest but
there's a lot of us who
um
don't know what it's like to be young
because it's been too long in my head
I'm 23 but I'm nowhere near 23 now so so
the first thing
think seriously about could you be a
counselor
because we need your life experiences
and the second thing
so my husband's also a counselor here
he left school with one
equivalent GCSE
and that's in geography
he didn't have maths he didn't have
English
he did English at
um on the correspondence course and then
when he was 27 he lost what was a really
boring not very well paid job
and he went to further education college
and he did an access to higher education
course
which was the equivalent of a levels he
then went to University
he then did a
post
I forgotten what it's called it was some
post degree qualification
and he had a really successful career in
social housing
and now he's he's been a counselor for
nearly 13 years
and so just if he didn't start out like
you intended it to or there's a bump in
the road that tripped you up
it doesn't mean that's it
and and between you you've got that
breadth of knowledge
that I wish I had
when I was doing by a levels
and you're going to set the world to
light and I can't wait to see so thank
you for giving up your evening to come
here and for all the preparation you've
done it's it's been wonderful thank you
I can only Echo that and the only word
of advice I would say and I have to say
four of my daughters actually all went
to
um
Trafford college or South traffic as it
was
um doing both a levels and Vocational
courses
um and all enjoyed the time there and I
think that's what has come through to me
um that you actually enjoy you've got
the the enthusiasm and I feel quite
inspired that that you you're so
passionate about what you're doing
um and I think as one or two people have
said life sometimes leads you in
different directions there are pitfalls
along the way but you pick yourself up
you just yourself off and
follow a different direction
I always think happiness
isn't
the end of a journey it's part of your
journey through life and what I've
always said to my children is
you can be whatever you want to be
that's up to you and that may change
over the years as people have mentioned
you may choose one path and then you may
see something else but those
opportunities are always there for you
and I'm sure you all are confident
enough
take those paths as they're presented to
you but thank you so so much for coming
to see us this evening and as I say it's
always my favorite meeting of the year
thanks to Michelle and her colleague who
for bringing them to us
um I don't know if you want to stay for
the end of the meeting or if you want to
leave us now it's entirely up to you
yeah if it's everybody happy to have
some photographs taken yeah yeah I think
we've done that in previous years so
yeah
look
I know I know
yeah I'm proud of them proud of all of
them
on behalf of all of my friends we would
like to thank you for listening to us
today hope to see you next year
hopefully
yeah yeah
I just I just can't believe how
confident and articulate they all were
but fantastic and to have that that
level full of confidence and knowledge
at such a young age
um I certainly wasn't that confident
um
okay
have we got
we're waiting for counselor Z to come
back
Okay so
before we go on I have been asked to
raise
an issue that we have with the lateness
of the reports
um
you know a lot of us still work a lot of
us have child care commitments
we really do need the reports seven days
in advance
um I mean these are both very in-depth
and very detailed reports
um
I know been contacted by two or three of
the committee members who have raised
concerns that we don't feel as though
we've had enough time to do them justice
so I don't know if anybody else would
like to yeah Shirley Johnson
I received the reports at 6 38 yesterday
evening when I was in a meeting I didn't
get home until half past nine
I haven't been able to read these I've
had other things I've had to do I don't
want to accept these reports tonight
because how can I do justice
to
as the nieces are already said something
that's really in depth
I don't want to skim anything I can't
scrutinize things effectively with
so little time between receiving the
report and then having the meeting it's
making my job impossible
and I would rather
end this meeting and carry them over
until the next one
because I cannot do my job effectively
and I can only apologize that to all
commit to all committee members and I
think one of the challenges that we had
was the the concertina ring of some
meetings I absolutely do appreciate that
you do need to have the the time to
scrutinize the reports and if that's
what committee feels is most appropriate
then obviously we'll have to abide by
the the wishes of of the committee
equally if there's things that you want
us to take offline in terms of any of
the depth of questions or things that
you think would be useful then of course
we'll be happy to do that and what I
wouldn't want the committee to do is to
see it as individual officer's
responsibility I say it's my
responsibility so I can only apologize
for that and note the concerns that have
been raised
okay
what do people think I'm going to take a
democratic view on this to do we want to
have these reports
um
heard in this meeting or do we want to
defer them
right okay
and he who would like to hear the
reports in this meeting
inside of
the end of the municipal year no it
won't be this is the last meeting right
so there would be an extra meeting
to to hear this there wouldn't be you
know
um and it could be a completely
different sense of committee
you can adjourn the meeting and then you
could reschedule another meeting if you
so wished that it's within your
abilities to do
have we've got time to do that we're
going to struggle time wise because
we're coming into the pre-election
period aren't we
uh yes it would be tight time frame um
all the reports and everything aren't
ready though so it'd be fun in an
evening when people are free to do it
um I'd say it's within your
um post to do it if you decide
um I can persuade you one way or the
other
okay
what do people think
Linda what do you think
I just feel though if if items are
deferred then that's going to then put
pressure of so so the new Municipal year
and I know exactly what council practice
is saying because you know this it's
very important this committee as as are
all committees but we are we are
committed to to help our young people
and children in the borough and it's and
it's for us to scrutinize but on the
other hand I don't want to to put
pressure on the councilors who are going
to be on the committee after May in
order to you know to deal with it and
um and you know the information that
that has been given to us it I think
it's important that you know that I
think that we hear the information
um you know and it says it is um it is a
filmed meeting and you know where people
people do follow who you know care about
you know the issues
so aiming what do you think I'm inclined
to agree with Linda I think yes it's
late and yes it was hard to get it read
but
putting it forward
[Music]
um
it I I I'm I am inclined to agree that
it's difficult it is difficult obviously
but I'm inclined to agree I think that
it's it makes sense we're here now like
Shirley says we've all got lots of other
commitments it's going to be difficult
to find a date
that we can all do we're all here and
do you think it makes sense to continue
Kath what did you like to say something
it was only to six it's not my committee
and and you know I I don't have a
obviously I'm not not suggesting I would
have a saying what happens I just
wondered if there was if there was an
agreement to proceed this evening if
that was the majority decision and I'm
not saying it will be whether there
might be an opportunity for members of
the committee to ask officers
um questions afterwards in you know if
if there's any questions that people
have because we've got Offices here who
might be able to to present some of the
detail that's in the reports but
appreciating what councilor Proctor and
others have said scrutinizing the
reports that's what we're here to do
isn't it so if just then follow-up
questions that people have got would
officers be open to people sort of
contacting them separately to perhaps
follow up if that was a I'm wondering
perhaps manage at some point an online
meeting for so in depth
um if that that could be an arrangement
because very often nothing thing
you think of questions after the event
anyway but I know people are really
struggling time wise but if we could
perhaps proceed I'm just trying to not
upset anybody here it's the last meeting
okay
um
but and then perhaps if we could have
the opportunity to if people can spare
it an hour of an evening and do it
online which isn't quite such a
I guess from the the service perspective
we're in your hands and we will do
whatever is is deemed the most
appropriate thing I think you know me
well enough and know the officers well
enough to know that we do actually
welcome and enjoy the The Challenge and
the scrutiny so we would want it to be a
meaningful process so you know please
don't think you're you're obsess us and
the work the work has taken place people
do have the detailed knowledge but if
it's felt that it's more appropriate on
balance to reconvene even if that is
online then we'll be guided by you or if
it's
um taking forward calf suggestion of
well let's at least hear the information
and follow up we're entirely in the
committee's hands okay Michael do you
have a view on this
it's a horrible uh situation being and I
have to say I only I only I mean I
didn't actually realize the reports
haven't been in because I only read them
this morning and that was always when I
was when I set myself some time to read
them so as far as I was concerned they
could have been there for two weeks and
um and I didn't actually I didn't
actually realize
um
it's difficult I I think we I think that
sounds like a good com it's you know
it's not it's it's a shame we need a
compromise but I think that sounds like
a good you know a good compromise that
we can look into them you know if we
have more questions we can look into
them we can discuss online
um I certainly think the new arrivals in
Trafford that's got some stuff
particularly about the Ashley hotel that
is very pressing for our particularly
certainly in our area and and I'd you
know quite like to discuss that tonight
because it is it is you know it's not
time critical but it's it's very
relevant it's very new information
um and uh I mean personally I'd like to
hear that discussed
so maybe yes I'll go for the compromise
if but don't want to
um I I very much understand where where
you're coming from I also understand
that the the calendar has been very
compressed you know and and we have to
um
uh and and we have to bear in mind the
pressures on officers because of because
of politics that was nothing to do with
their their you know their their
decision making either so
did you do you want to comment at all
um issue I think you were showing the
students out which was very kind of you
but the issue we've had is the reports
were very very late and we've not really
had a chance to scrutinize them properly
um so
we're just asking for people's views on
whether we should defer them to a later
meeting or whether to have them
presented this evening with an
opportunity for us to scrutinize the
papers more thoroughly
and then perhaps
have the opportunity to ask questions or
whether that be online or via email
um at a later date
yeah I I'm okay for a deferred this
report and then we can have another
discussion uh next time yes I'm okay for
that yeah
okay
so
chilly would you be happy with for us to
hear the hear the reports this evening
and have a more in-depth discussion if
we can arrange something say in a week
or if those time I don't actually see
the point I didn't even know that the
Ashley Hotel was in That's how little
time I've been able to
spend on this
I have had no opportunity to
to do what I normally do when I get
committee reports which is read them
thoroughly make notes do my own research
find out about things
and then develop some questions I've had
no opportunity to do that
so
having the reports print presented to us
is just
to be honest a waste of my evening when
I haven't got the opportunity to ask any
questions
so if we're going to have an opportunity
to have questions at another date why
don't we just do the whole thing on
another date
because I cannot do my job tonight
okay and it's the role of scrutiny is
too important
to
to not do it effectively and I think
that's what we would be doing if we said
oh well never mind we got it last night
we'll we'll listen
because that isn't scrutinizing okay I
do appreciate what you're saying I've
done scrutiny for 11 years now and I do
appreciate what you're saying I'm going
to take the Democratic route here and
put it to the vote
so
those of us those of you that would like
to proceed with the meeting tonight
can you indicate
I've got three
no obviously
and those of us that would prefer to
defer the meeting entirely to another
date
two
three four proceeding was it
so I'd be to proceed I mean you I
haven't casted a vote so yeah I'm going
to go with the majority
um I'm sorry
um but I just think if if the majority
of people have come this evening our
officers have attended this evening as
well I think we should proceed
um but
I would like to
um reiterate that we do want the
opportunity to
scrutinize these reports in more depth
okay
so can we move on to the news do you
mind if I leave because yeah
thank you
do you need us to move
oh Alex will we still be quiet
yeah okay
do you are you going to be presenting
all right no okay yeah
[Laughter]
good evening I'll I'll take you through
the presentation counselors I'm just
going to
um go through a number of different
types of new arrivals that we've had in
Trafford over the past couple of years
just give a brief overview on on some of
those in a little bit more detail around
the uh Ukrainian and the current sound
seeking families and at the Britannia
hotel in in Hale there's there's some
national context within the slabs that I
want I won't spend a a great deal of
time because I think members will be
more interested in the Trafford position
but we did just want to put it in the
context of what's been happening
nationally and internationally and so we
we start with our Hong Kong settlement
program and I think seamlessly really
from the young people that we we heard
from from the college there's many
positives of having new arrivals uh in
in Trafford for a children and young
people point of view and the families
and the job skills and Entrepreneurship
which has been integrated into the local
community there are um 817 residents in
Trafford born in Hong Kong
at the 2021 census which I I think is is
powerful bigger
there are groups of children who who
arrive unaccompanied
um many of you will have seen on on the
news the situation at some of the the
borders of the country but we we can
have spontaneous
um unaccompanied children at any time
arriving some of them
um do come through agreed roots and we
have um
a regional Asylum team that help us with
some of that but some young people do do
arrive we had one young person last week
actually who arrived in our reception
um one day having arrived in in Trafford
unaccompanied and under 18. So currently
we have 15 cared for children who are
unaccompanied that is that their their
parent or Guardian is not with them in
this country and we are looking after
those children and in a range of
Provisions some of that is in foster
care
um others in our residential homes we
have two residential homes in Trafford
both of whom have had unaccompanied
um a sound seeking children and have
done an absolutely fantastic job
um of of of understanding their culture
being able to um
to research people in our local area and
in greater Manchester that can support
them and we also have um 18
care leavers sorry who are age 18 to 25
who were formally unaccompanied who we
are continuing to support
and and that support is
um is the same as any other cared for or
care leaving child will receive
um as outlined in the local offer and
that's around education at Health
employment and accommodation and wanting
to provide them with that stability and
security to enable them to succeed
and moving on to the Ukraine there's a
couple of slides there which are in the
National context which will be familiar
with in terms of the number of people
um in in the UK but in terms of
trafford's position in slide seven we
have undertaken from our early Health
Services
120 initial home visits to families face
to face since the 30th of March last
year
we've been working really closely with
colleagues in the council and with
Partners the community hubs have been an
imperative really for supporting these
families who arrived here
the the initial home visit includes um a
home condition checklist for those
sponsored families to make sure that the
home is suitable and safe for the family
um there are no Ukrainian families who
have progressed who've needed services
that have progressed to a coordinated
team around the family approach and I
think that's a real Testament to some of
those sponsor families really and the
support that they have given
um those families we we have offered
continual telephone
um signed posting
um to those families alongside some um
at school
um support as well
so there's a couple of slides there
which are in terms of looking at the the
support that
um Services have have provided and I'm
not sure whether Karen wants to come in
in terms of of the schooling situation
we've got that threaded threaded through
the presentation
oh thank you Pamela
um absolutely I mean I think
um probably we've
um covered off quite a bit of of
information around school Place planning
for our new arrivals into Trafford on on
many occasions but
um I think for me what what really
stands out is how we've managed to
accommodate
um these fantastic families
um and and young people that have moved
into our Borough
um and really that's been because of the
fabulous relationships we have with our
schools and the fact that our schools
have have really opened their arms to
welcoming these young people
um into their Provisions
um many of these young people
um we use our fat process Our Fair
access protocol to place these children
and young people
um and I remember just sitting in a
meeting with all of the primary heads in
the sale and Ultraman area and saying
okay what can we do together here and it
was it was just fantastic to see all of
the heads stepping up and an offering to
to welcome these families into their
schools so we we have absolutely the
admissions team working hand in hand I
think with the schools themselves have
really worked hard in Partnership to to
ensure that our children and young
people were placed at PACE really so
that they didn't miss out on extensive
periods of Education one of the lovely
success story that we had we actually
um managed to employ a Hong Kong lady
into our admissions service which was
just wonderful for her to be able to
link in and liaise directly with some of
our families and have that shared
experience I think and just just that
relationship and knowledge and
understanding was was just lovely and we
also know broad Oak and themselves took
um quite a significant number of Afghan
pupils from Manchester a hotel in
Manchester and again agreed to take the
whole of those young people into their
school and I know the feedback from that
has been absolutely significant because
I think it's kept the community together
as well transport was arranged and it
was just again such a lovely success
story and a great piece of work what are
family information service do is we make
sure that we support the families in
terms of what they can what they're
entitled to and the support that they
can get
um for for things just provision of
uniforms or School meals and those sorts
of things so the family information
service again will will work with our
families and the schools to make sure
that they're really clear about what's
available to them
um and and certainly just the Ashley
hotel for example we've literally been
working with our schools this week to
make sure that those young people and
children have got a school Place we've
managed to place the primary school
children into alteringham church of
England school and Stanford Park Primary
and the secondary school students are
going to wellacre and flixton girls and
again we've arranged transport around
that so we've just been able to move at
PACE where we can and you know for me
it's just a massive thanks to our
admissions service and family
information service but mostly
significantly our schools as well who've
just worked so hard to to place these
children just finally what I will say is
obviously the children do come with a
whole range of needs and we have
LinkedIn with we don't have an eal
service and English as an additional
language support service for our schools
but Stockport do and the providers there
used to be Trafford officers actually so
we've got good links in with them and
again we made sure we put a clinic on
for our school heads so that they they
with with the um Stockport Services just
so that they could see what help could
be given just to to help them with with
meeting the children's needs when they
actually arrive at school thank you
I think one of the the most powerful
Slavs is the feedback from families on
slide 10
um you know they're they're relaying
back to us that they feel that the
Ukrainian families that they've received
a higher level of support in the
community and a lot of practical help as
well they've been supported in that
transition from sponsorship arrangements
to Independent Living very much
appreciated what Karen's uh highlighted
there that prompt response in terms of
school admissions our youth engagement
service
um very very early days for some of our
Ukrainian young people established and a
youth group that has been really well
received and well attended and that's
taken place at talk shop and we have
undertaken some some direct work with
specific children as well
um who where from that youth club it's
been it's transpired that they've needed
a little bit more support really
in terms of um
safeguarding from a Ukrainian children
perspective we do have five children
from Ukraine who were unaccompanied so
their legal guardian and wasn't able to
accompany them and one is nine two or 15
116 and 117 and we
um have been advised nationally and
regionally to to treat those children as
privately fostered children and so we
followed the the relevant procedures and
checks there and more frequent visiting
to those homes because those those
children are are on their own
moving on to the the situation
um in in Hale at the Britannia hotel and
as members will be aware we we were
notified just before Christmas that
there were plans to use the hotel
um for Asylum seeking people
um we thought at that point that it was
it was going to be predominantly uh
single males
um that situation changed uh and as of
the 10th of February a number of
families
um arrived not all at the same time it
was of that a two-week period and we we
currently have 118 people residing at
the hotel 59 of whom are our children
you can see some of the the breakdown in
terms of gender and the the range of
places where where people have have come
from we
um as we did with our Ukrainian families
had a partnership response to that led
by Richard raw and and his support team
and bringing together health screening
at the outset and we do have we do have
a couple of children with some complex
Health needs within within that group
that we're we're supporting as well so
there was um through Public Health
um a bespoke service commissioned around
some of that um health screening
immunizations
Etc and a GP on site
um for the first few weeks
so we've we've talked about some of the
impacts and challenges there with with
regards to to schooling
um there are cultural language support
and needs that we are working with um
with the hotel and with circle who was
the the partner
um that deliver some of those practical
Services the food the the clothes
washing Etc so we've had um our staff
and family help at the hotel on a number
of occasions and looking to extend that
really because even when the children
will be in school we know that this that
continue to be some and some needs
really to occupy the children
particularly in the evenings and
weekends so we're looking to ensure that
that support is is broadened as well and
there has been as there was with the
Ukrainian families I remember being at
Stratford town hall for the welcome
event for our Ukrainian families there
has been a level of of welcoming in the
community and in addition to some
concerns that have been raised as well
so we're continuing to to work as a as a
council and and a partnership in terms
of integrating and in those families
into the community and ensuring that
they have the right support
thanks uh both of you does anybody have
any questions
counselor z
uh thank you uh in your report talking
about Hong Kong Integrations you
mentioned there are some Safeguard
issues I just want to understand uh what
is that uh you say some safeguardian
concerns due to different cultural norms
I would understand what is that and any
typical example on how do you solve the
issues
so I think there are there are two areas
um where where we've had some um some
referrals and some um conversations with
families one of those is around physical
chastisement
and so we've had some referrals through
schools usually of children sharing some
issues of physical chastisement which
um in some circumstances is less
bruising so that within our safeguarding
procedures are followed in those
circumstances and there have been some
uh situations where where children have
been left home alone for periods of time
where people go and shopping or for you
know running practical errands and and
that's not
purely in response in response to the
Hong Kong arrivals we found that that is
for new arrivals generally some of our
Eastern European families and have
different cultural norms around ages to
be able to leave children so part of our
role within that is around that
education uh of of the the kind of
legislative Frameworks that we're
working too and in in the United Kingdom
so it's a it's a it's a support and a an
enabling that integration really and
that understanding
uh thank you for this explanation I
think that probably naturally links to
my second question in the following page
you mentioned you are providing some
family services including different
cultural language supports I just
wondering were you dealing with these
cases are you facing any language or
culture difference if so to to to do you
provide any cultural or language support
to those silent Seekers
include the Hong Kong Community yeah
yeah that that is in place we would we
would always make sure that on on any
visits to families where there were any
concerns that we we would we would
always take an interpreter with us to
ensure that there's that full
understanding and that full conversation
and then there will be that that
assessment of what support is is needed
on an ongoing basis really and some of
that will be around language and culture
thank you
yes please
um on um slide four
um on the company the silence seeking
children and then in Brackets you've got
deemed under 18 when arrived is there
any issue with
individuals who aren't under 18 or is it
have you just put that in as a
as you know something that has has to be
done from a legal point of view
it is it is very much a requirement for
us to undertake an age assessment so we
do have and have worked elsewhere in in
the region as well we do sometimes have
people presenting as being under 18 and
we are not so sure that they are so that
we we would need to undertake that full
assessment really
um and there's there's a range of um
tools and advice around around that some
of that is is very much uh research in
terms of the point of entry and where
that young person stroke adult arrived
in the country and so we will we will
undertake those thorough checks and and
balances really but in the in the
interim period we would always treat
them as a child whilst we were
conducting those inquiries and we would
ensure that they had a safe place to
stay if I can just add to that
um obviously age assessments are
conducted in accordance with the
legislation or a very thorough process
but actually identifying someone's age
where there's a question of uncertainty
is is very challenging and that might be
because somebody has come through a
traumatic set of circumstances and might
not be clear about what their legal age
is so it it's not as if we can carry out
medical tests to
um
pinpoint somebody's age and that would
be overly intrusive that would be
inappropriate so there is a level of
professional judgment applied to to the
assessments but as Pamela's pointed out
um we would always ER on the side of of
caution in terms of if somebody is
um presenting as being under 18 if our
professional judgment through having
carried out that thorough assessment is
that we think that's more than likely
then we would actually treat that young
person as a young person
sorry I think everybody heard was a sad
but just just for the camera if um if
after the initial period where they were
supported have families moved on to to
live independently
I don't have cancer apologies I don't
have the exact figures I think on in the
in the feedback from families
um what they were saying is they've
they've felt very well supported to
manage that transition and I do I do
know of several families that have moved
on to
um
secure their own tenancies be that
rented or through all the means in in
Trafford and some families that have
chosen to move out of Trafford
um I think with a number of families
that have moved into Lancashire
um where there's they had connections
with other people that were sponsored
there so it's been very much on an
individual Case by case basis there are
there are other families that have the
the horse has chosen to continue
um with that Arrangement rather than
um support that transition so it has
been very much each individual family
circumstances has been supported really
I could ask Karen something with regard
to the um the Ukraine children and the
Hong Kong children and if they are
traveling to a school which isn't within
walking distance and you said that they
they were given help in order to get to
school is that is that like a free bus
pass or or is it they're actually taken
to the school so could it could have
just fine because you know obviously if
it's out of statutory
um distance or walking distance or
whether it's those time scales
absolutely it fit within the transport
policy I think um the broad Oak
situation that was actually
um facilitated by broad Oak themselves
so they arranged the transport
negotiated it so to transport the young
people from Manchester hotel to Broad
Oak so they put that in themselves
um the situation with the secondary
students from the Ashley hotel is
something that we've managed to arrange
um
the the students from the Ashley Hotel
have there isn't any funding wrapped
around those young people
um as has been applied previously
um with with the Ukraine
um young people in particular so we've
actually managed to locate some
additional funds to be able to support
these young people passporting it over
to the schools but also supporting some
of the transporting issues
I think it's um
think thinking about like from a
safeguarding angle if you've got if
you've got children young people that
are traveling a distance to a school
English isn't isn't the first language
they don't know the area and I just
thought it yeah absolutely
yeah that's these these after you know
going through whatever they've gone
through that that if they feel safe
absolutely
um yeah well so at the moment this week
well acre and flixton are doing
um almost transition arrangements so
they're doing welcoming events
um and so families will be traveling
with the young people to the school so
that um as well as our family
information service representatives are
transporting with them just so that they
know which is the entrance that they go
to just all of those you know really
important practical steps so they've
been supported this week to absolutely
um manage that
um next week you know hopefully they'll
be independent enough to to manage the
transport themselves
um some of the schools do actually do
all sorts of buddying arrangements as
well just to support them so again that
will be arranged via the schools through
their transitioning in but with
absolutely being clear that we will
support the families and the young
people as they make those first Journeys
to ensure that they're really clear
about what to do and where they're going
um so yeah we put that we put those
mechanisms in could I just ask
um is is there extra support to the
schools themselves to ensure that the
the the young people feel integrated
within the school because you know
sometimes
children aren't always kind to all the
children and it's it and that can then
put a burden on on teaching and support
staff with in whichever educational
establishments it is absolutely I mean
before we actually
um agreed the school Place position we
actually brought the primary school
heads together and we brought the
secondary school heads together at the
primary school has just in the ultramum
area the secondary we brought them all
together and said okay what do you think
is the best way forward here so it
really came from them when we knew that
they were invested in in whatever the
arrangements were going to look like and
it was during that meeting that
certainly flexed in a while like I said
we're more than happy to do that as I
say we are passporting funding over to
the schools themselves so they need to
buy an additional support whether that
be eal support or whether it be a
physical support to to really work with
these young people they've got that
funding and we're going to certainly
make sure that that's brought into the
schools as quickly as possible
um but the schools were really clear
that they had the infrastructure and the
services that they would need in the
first instance to you know to to really
help those students I I do agree that I
think it's only once we get to know the
students and the children that will
really understand the levels of need but
again that's where we're going to have
to come at it as a multi you know as a
partnership approach really to wrap that
support around them if I can just come
in in terms of some of the additional
um areas that we're looking at from a
partnership point of view we are looking
at what support may be needed from a
health perspective thinking particularly
in terms of the complexity of need and I
don't mean that from a disability point
of view but from an experiential point
of view So currently we're having
conversations with our colleagues from I
want to say the former ccg which I know
isn't the the right name for them but
with colleagues from Trafford NHS ICS
um teams in terms of what that support
might look like because it's only right
and proper that we think about if people
have come to a different country if
they've already been moved from one part
of the country to another
um and are now in hotel accommodation
that they're all likely to be a number
of needs emanating from that one of the
points on the the slides that was
highlighted and I know it's something
that Karen's teams have have been
proactive in
just that need to be able to play and be
and have activities so the the whole
multi-agency approach is something that
we're taking forward just also to add to
that Council of Blackburn we know that
for example School nursing there will be
targeted School nursing support in those
various schools so I think that that is
it as a direct response of the needs of
some of these children so that's already
been agreed
going to spend so
it's just few months time but
um when it comes to the summer holidays
which is going to be a long time that
these young people and are not going to
be you know in oops the educational
um sort of set setting
um do we know what other support will be
given to you know to either you know the
Hong Kong children uh Ukraine or or from
from wherever
I mean I think normally where we've got
some funding around to support some of
the summer school activities
um you know certainly that offer what
we've done previously is made sure we
prioritize vulnerable children and young
people to access that that level of
support and just those activities over
the summer so that's something that we
can work with the likes of sports
partnership
um or even
um you know some of I don't know
multi-agency Services really to see what
what the offer is a lot of schools will
already offer some level of school
activities over the summer and but I
think we just need to make sure we
target it to the vulnerable pupils it's
something I can certainly take away and
discuss with the schools as well
I say thank you for this it's it's it's
you know it's a lot of a lot of work and
it's you know there are lots of you know
it's not just impacted on the the
children and young people that have come
to Trafford but all children in in our
schools and in our you know different
areas and it's it's been a very
interesting report thank you very much
oh my God
yeah thank you um I've had Direct
experience of of of the issues that are
in are in this report because one of
those single mothers who's currently in
the hotel was living with me until the
end of November in our house
um and uh she was she arrived before the
home to Ukraine scheme was set up and we
took her in when she when they
um were in found to be in unsuitable
accommodation in in
um in Manchester we took them in
thinking we'd be able to have them under
the homes Ukraine scheme uh eventually
and we couldn't because they were
already in the country
uh they were very very quickly put uh
the daughters very quickly put into
navigation Primary School which is just
behind the house probably the first
Ukrainian to be accommodated which is
absolutely fantastic it's where my kids
went and uh
um and they lit LED I mean a
comparatively Blissful six months until
the home office actually
um finally started working for them and
actually because
um and uh because they wanted they put
in a in for accommodation support
financial support pretty much as soon as
they arrived the home office or is this
the just the contrast between the chaos
at the home office and what's happening
at Trafford could not be Starker and
they um suddenly in November Ataxia a
taxi was sent to our house and they were
ripped from our house
to uh temporary accommodation in
Carlisle so the so the young child so
that Anna
five years old
missed five weeks of school while she
was in this temporary accommodation in
Carlisle they were then
um you know the uh Alex her mother
fought hard and she was that they
brought her back to North London to that
Britannia hotel in North London which is
no no picture no I believe me and
um and then you know whatever one may
think of the suitability of the Ashley
Hotel it was a fortunate for them that
that was then open because they've now
been moved to there and at least they
were within at least walking distance of
navigation Primary School
but
the trauma that this must be causing for
the little girl is you know I mean and
the mother is is unbelievable and I've
got it you know just just I mean I feel
I really should use this opportunity to
to read this is a doctor's letter which
is in support of her Asylum claim that
says Anna is currently living in her
third contingency third contingency
Hotel she's been moved three times since
18th of November 2022 and he's finding
it difficult to adapt to the environment
her mother informs me that there is a
lot of noise around their room and that
there are children playing outside the
room in the corridors until late hours
of night she's having sleep problems and
struggle struggles to get adequate rest
and she's finding the environment
stressful and gets upset and cries
frequently this is causing PSD like PTSD
like symptoms and I you know uh I could
go on and really you know I mean I I
think it's a huge credit to you for
getting them into the in into schools
because that this you know the school
placement is where they will get their
stability from and it will be Haven for
them and a nutritional Haven as well
because the food in those hotels is not
you know is it is not um good either
um so you know so so thank you for doing
that um so swiftly I mean it's just
insane the fact that you know she's from
Ukraine she's from junipro they're
they're you know what an apartment block
similarly similar to the one that they
live in was bombed just recently killing
40 people you know the fact that their
immigration claim has not been processed
yet is absolutely ridiculous you know
she speaks really good English she could
be working productively for the economy
you know in the economy and
um and uh and she can't because the the
system is so slow
uh the question I'd like to I've got a
couple other questions about a quick
principal question I like to ask is is
are we able to provide any immigration
support to the people in the you know in
the hotel to help them process that you
know get their claims move forward
I mean in terms of progressing claims we
can provide advice and support of course
clearly it's a legal issue and it's it
is one that is is complex but we can
provide and we do provide advice and
support in in that regard including for
our unaccompanied
um young people as well as people that
have come in through through the the
situation in in Ukraine one of the
things that I would say and and it's
reflected in in some of um the story
that you've been able to share there is
um
the generosity of people in Trafford and
I think it's really important that we do
do recognize that because there was such
a strong altruistic response to the
homes for Ukraine from from Trafford as
Karen's already
um articulated our schools have
um overcome logistical and practical
problems in order to extend that welcome
and I think your point is is really well
made that actually school is a place of
safety and it provides stability and it
provides structure and routine and when
you've had multiple moves when you've
got all of the trauma that you've just
described really articulately having
that structure having that routine and
having that nurturing is really really
important and so yes we can provide
advice and support no we can't provide
the legal advice directly but we can
point people to solicitors to those
legal firms that do have the expertise
and the knowledge in terms of of um
navigating what is inevitably a complex
system
and thank you yes I mean she speaks very
good English so she you know she's a
fighter and she you know she has managed
to get various you know organizations
working helping her and working with us
you know it hasn't just been hasn't just
been us so yes it's obviously it's more
of a it's a concern this is a concern
for her but also for those people who
haven't who don't have very good English
and that kind of thing must be so much
harder for them to be able to articulate
their you know their their their work on
their cases thank you very much for
sorry just the other biters in terms of
some of that support we have got
engagement of the likes of care for
Calais and um third sector organizations
Charities that again do have expertise
in terms of asylum in Immigration and we
we certainly have seen some successes
from engaging with with our third sector
Partners as well thank you very much
um the just the other quick questions uh
just wondering if I mean if the old
stream Community hubs obviously once
again
um giving fantastic uh support um Rachel
and we've credited to Rachel mooter and
the team there um for what they do um
and I just wondering have they been
provided have they been provided with
any extra resource or uh
um are they doing out of you know the
existing funds that they get in the
short answer yes there has been some
looking at the profiling of the funding
for the hubs both in the short term and
in on a more sustainable basis I don't
have the details of what that looks like
but we can provide that but yes there
has been some immediate financial
support and recognition of that
extension of what they're needing to do
thank you and joy the the primary
schools that the kids have gone well
could you just run that list of schools
again because
yeah they've um alteringham Church of
England Primary School have taken the
majority of of the young people that
includes Nursery age children as well so
again we're trying to get the children
in as early as possible which is is just
fantastic and Stanford part primary and
I know Stanford Park is open so if we do
see any change any more additional
families coming into the hotel are Keen
to take those additional pupils too and
that's all the children have been
accommodated now wow yeah brilliant yeah
fantastic fantastic news councilor Z did
you remember
question I'm just conscious of the time
and we have got another item yeah um
I've got counselor Z and then
um
Council Hines
thank you yeah uh thank you for all the
hard work is really really great under
page 15 you mentioned uh schools across
Trafford are full uh so that make me
wondering uh yes we are prioritizing
dealing with silent Seekers children and
also being our children's but how about
our local children can we still provide
enough space for local children go to
local schools
I'm going to ask Karen to come in but
the short answer is we have met our
school play sufficiency Duty book
current will give yeah I think there's
two different routes that's the thing so
in terms of the
um art our statutory Duty sits with
placing children in reception and year
seven so it's just those two year groups
that we have a statutory Duty in terms
of of the offers for our families
any additional State any children that
are in year that's where we apply the
fair access protocol now if we can place
children in year without having to go
through the fair access protocol because
there's already existing vacancies then
that's what we'll do otherwise we as I
say we apply the fat uh and and in the
fair access protocol we have meetings
where we bring all of the heads together
all of the schools together talk about
the children that we have and the young
people that we have to place and it is
about it's where those families or those
young people have exhausted all the
processes to access the school
and obviously the very vulnerable
children need to need to be prioritized
so we then will bring the schools
together and that's where places will be
allocated
if we do have schools that refuse
because it does happen
and obviously we need grounds for that
refusal as to why they can't if they're
a maintained school we can direct the
local Authority will direct the virtual
school can direct if they looked after
children
um if it's an academy we we absolutely
try and negotiate and I do pick up the
phone and let's talk to the heads
um because otherwise then I have to
refer it to the regional director who
then it will be a secretary of state
decision so
um fortunately we've not needed to to
really get to that stage the other thing
that I think has really been absolutely
brilliant actually to hear from our
grammar schools and our selective system
if we have a student coming through
um fap who actually we feel like they
could be eligible for a grammar school
place
they are willing to step up an entrance
exam quickly so that again if if
eligible if they pass those young people
can also get into a grammar school which
is just fantastic as well and and the
other thing that our grammar schools
have offered because it is difficult
when we're in a selective system but the
other thing that they have offered is
either mentoring support from their
students to help the other secondary
colleagues and students in in the
existing non-selective schools or just
you know considering how we can work
together to share resources as well so I
think it's been really powerful in
bringing the school Community together
foreign
do you want to just say a few words only
very briefly I just wanted to thank
officers really because
um I think trafford's response has been
tremendous actually
um and I think officers and council's
response has been it's been coordinated
it's been organized
um and most importantly most importantly
I think it's been incredibly
compassionate and likewise with um the
schools and the community as well so I
just wanted to say thank you
thank you I think you know Trafford this
is what we do when
when we put on the spot we work together
and we get it done don't we
um so yeah congratulations and many
thanks to officers
um I'm going to move on to
um item seven which is the children's
placements savings proposals we have had
the report or be we haven't had a chance
to scrutinize it properly but um if you
could give us a whistles I'm just
conscious that people will want to get
home and
some people including me haven't eaten
yet this evening
if you could give us a whistle top
Whistle Stop tour through it please yeah
so I'm you'll be pleased to know it
won't it won't be me throughout
um my adults at times
um I'm just gonna kind of give a context
of of what we're going to go through in
terms of giving you an overview of of
the the budget the children's placement
budget and what's that made made up of
commitment and savings that we've
already achieved in in the past several
years what some of the demand pressures
and current position statements are and
our challenges and longer term plans for
the future so I'm on slide two there you
can see the breakdown of of what makes
up the quite substantial children's
placement budget
um hot off the press and it it includes
a 12.5 inflation and which was um a a
decision that the minister took to to
increase all national fostering minimum
allowances um by 12.5 percent and that's
that's been finalized today with
colleagues from finance and we we
haven't one million pound demography
Edition that comes into the budget but
in effect
um that that that
goes out of the budget in the savings so
one million in one million out
um which we we have achieved during the
past
um three three years and and slightly
over achieved in the last couple of
years as well
so that the budget that we have is set
for our existing children so we we are
now lower than statistical never uh
comparators for the number of AD cared
for children that we have through
implementing a number of strategies
which which Glenn will will talk a
little bit about but any any new
children coming into care need to be
offset by children either exiting the
care system or a reduction a step down
of their placement costs
um so there there was a a 1.44 million
budget additional spend in Period eight
in
2022-23 so I suppose what we're saying
there is is pressure there's pressure in
that budget system because we we can't
always predict what is going to come
through the front door and how many
children we're going to need to take
into care
um at any one time and it it I think it
links to the piece that you have also on
the agenda around children's emotional
mental health as well we the the
additional expenditure in Period a is
predominantly around children with
emotional mental health difficulties
some of whom are stepping down into
placements from tier four provision in
mental health within NHS
we have 12 children who have significant
additional needs we did talk about that
in the last presentation where we
detailed the sufficiency strategy that
we have a number of children who have
complex physical and learning needs
which require
um
High Staffing levels and usually
residential provision two of those
children we we have aspiration that they
they can move into a family and but that
is going to be challenging to to meet
due to the the level of their needs but
the remaining 10 will need to stay where
they are
um until they are 18 and they will will
transition into Adult Services
yeah so on slide six I've tried I'm
trying to sort of just demonstrate the
demand and pressure that's in the system
at the moment so what we the external
the average external residential
placement cost is around five and a half
thousand pounds
our most expensive young person
currently is fourteen thousand seven
hundred pounds per week and it's a young
person again in the same vein as what
Palmer said you know with real complex
mental health needs um and actually
that's a step out of a um of a secure
setting in into that into that
we know that you know for chill for lots
of our young people where they come with
the home fosterings the you know the
most appropriate setting for them to
live in and what we've seen both in
Trafford and of course great and
Manchester and across sort of North West
is a reduction in the number of internal
Foster carers that we've got so you know
as I talked in the last presentation
around the pieces of work we're doing
our sufficiency around that sort of
Greater Manchester project we're going
to hopefully see some of that increase
over the next couple of years but when
we haven't got an internal fostering
placement we will look at an independent
fostering agency as we've referred to an
eye for where we know the average cost
is around 889 pounds a week
what we found within the IFA setting as
well as the Foster carers that they've
had and they just like local authorities
are struggling to recruit new Foster
carers so some of the
children I'll talk about my next slide
around where they are and costs is is
around you know when we've got the
absence of fostering placement we've had
to place them in a residential
Children's Home which isn't part of our
care plan so we do have plans in place
for a number of children to look at
stepping down from residential back into
fostering placements where we can you
know find a suitable match just in terms
of the demand around sort of what we'll
look you know when we're looking for
placements you know 54 of the referrals
our commission team work with Arthur
fostering placements that's a 50
increase on two years previously so
again the demand has increased over the
last couple of years
as promised I've got 12 um young people
with additional needs that are currently
in residential settings and as we said
10 of them are likely to remain in those
types of Provisions in in the longer
term we've got 19 children that
currently live in external residential
placements and that costs us on average
at the moment 3.6 million pounds a year
to look after those 19 children in their
current settings with our most expensive
provision being nearly 15 000 pounds a
week with the average framework
placement being around 15 around 5 000
um pounds a week what I've tried to do
on slide 7 just show you if we were able
to move children from an external
residential into either a knife of
fostering placement or an internal
fostering placement there are for a
single young person there is up to an
early course of a million pound savings
to be you know more cost avoidance you
know that children still be will be
looked after
um so as you can see sort of the current
average cost of placements most
expensive as you expect external
residential you know
um right down to us sort of our special
guardianship orders and what our um
Gardens receiving payments
we're trying we're doing a piece of work
in terms of obviously cost of living
we've talked about before and obviously
providers in line with cost living are
asking to increase their their fees so
obviously that's an additional added
pressure to the budget
so we're working as we said talked about
previous presentation workings of closer
relationships with local providers you
know and be able to negotiate the
uplifts um when we do get a fee uplifts
we're asking the providers you know to
to expand the rationale behind that so
it's not just an email that comes
through to the commission team we agree
there's a whole set of you know work
that needs to be under completed and
we're also working with our along the
northwest of our placement Northwest
colleagues to really come up with a
really um consistent approach that we're
all taking and obviously as we get into
16 you know we talked previous about 16
plus becoming regulated so we're taking
a slightly different approach with our
16 plus providers as well
just to sort of give assurances that we
do have lots of what we call Budget
management controls within the local
Authority in terms of you know that we
we appreciate you you know the
children's placements is one of the most
expensive areas of a budget in the
council so we have um three sort of
things in place of a high cost placement
Clinic which um Pamela chairs on a
monthly basis and we're looking at the
spend of all of those external
residential placements those independent
fostering agency placements and we're
looking at you know work of our Health
Partners as well to think about you know
contributions where children have
diagnosis
um through our Imad panel which I've I
probably forgot off my head which
abbreviation means but also within that
meeting trying to look at step down
Arrangements you know as we said for
those 19 young people that are in
residential care not all of them need to
be there whilst we also look at our
internal sufficiency as well I'm going
to say there's the further project
control because everything that goes to
Pamela at that monthly Clinic comes into
our senior management team for scrutiny
and challenge including from myself in
terms of the costs thanks Jill we have
the external placement panel which I
chair so that's where all new requests
um for provision and for children to be
placed but also when there's any
increasing costs and again that goes
through you know me and Pam have regular
discussions in relation to those
increasing in changes of costs and then
I have regular meetings with our finance
colleagues in terms of place and budget
review meetings
just want to go for a number just very
very quickly through these slides just
want to sort of show the work we have
done previously in terms of reduction of
um the number of children that have been
cared for so we know in in December 20
we had around we had 410 children but we
you know be able to step that down
safely and appropriately in our current
numbers of careful children is at 345 so
we've seen 55 children come out you know
of being cared for for various different
reasons and therefore it has you know
where we talk about savings previously
there has been some savings made by you
know by reducing the number of cared for
children we talked about previously that
we've had a high proportion in in
Trafford of children living at home with
parents on a care order where we should
continue to share MPR again we've
reduced that down from 89 down to 50
individual um children young people at
the moment so again it really
demonstrates the work that we've done
here in children's services to to reduce
the number of children home and Care
orders
in terms of number of children internal
fostering placements it's remain very
stable so what we've done even though
we've reduced on the number of foster
carers have reduced the occupancy of
those existing Foster carers have remain
really high so we'd be able to maintain
the number of children that have lived
there and with what we've been really
successful to date is special Garden
supporters that we've achieved in terms
of children that have lived in Connected
care and placements where they've now
been safely discharged from care and
living you know with their special
Gardens we've done 14
um today
um for this year
in terms of external um eye for
placements I've talked about there was a
steady declined around 18 months ago but
we've seen that slowly creep back up
again over the last um three years and
again that's in line with some of the
reduction in the number of internal
Foster carers that we've had but also
about the demands of children need to be
looked after the use of external
children's homes over is that 19 what
we've seen is a very slow decline the
positive news that hasn't significantly
risen
on slide 14 it's really for your
information which just gives you a bit
of an overview of the different types of
provisions and placements that are cared
for children and living so I believe
that for your reading for that
obviously in terms of sort of demand
management strategy what we're really
clear about is that you know right
you're on the right placement up to the
right length of time and there's been
you know ongoing work in terms of sort
of quality of leisure and practice it
within social care that contributes to
um you know reduction number of care for
children and supports with some of the
work we're doing around the budgets but
you know what we're trying to do is
obviously do prevention work to prevent
children coming into the camp which
don't you know we're doing work
certainly for children with additional
needs to make sure that we can keep
children at home safely with short break
packages to avoid those young people
coming in to Care on you know and
effectively go into 52-week placements
obviously want to improve the equality
of our assessments and Care planning um
because obviously what we do if we get
if we make decisions right earlier then
it again prevents children becoming
cared for and potentially going to
expensive high cost placements and
obviously we've implemented a permanent
and sufficiency strategy
um which I'm one of the co-leads on and
obviously we've got a no wrong door
model which you'll be familiar with in
previous meetings which with very much
in the implementation stage at the
moment and that's a real you know Clear
Vision in terms of keeping adolescent
young people who are on the edge of Care
at home and not needing to come into the
care of a local Authority
I think what's really really important
to to highlight is when we think about
although we've you know reduced them
with care for children but we know that
we continue to support
um care experience young people post 18
up to 25
um so at the moment we've got 77 young
people in that sort of 16 to 17 bracket
that will become care experienced in the
next 12 18 months but we've got 163
young people 10 to 15. so in the future
I'm predicting our future demand
thinking about you know appropriate
suitable accommodation 16 plus supported
tenancy the house project Etc we've got
a huge number of young people coming
through in future years which we'll have
to think about as we move forward how
we're going to best support those um
those care experience young people
um the 16 plus unregulated placement I
talked about some last time we I came to
um scrutiny so I I won't repeat what I
said previously in terms of that I
suppose current challenges and pressure
again you know we've got the increase in
demand and complexity of need which
obviously impacts on you know cost of
cost of provision as Pamela said you
know we're talking believe in the next
items about young people mental health
and those young people are in crisis
they tend to be the ones that come be
cared for and cost more money because we
need to specifically bespoke
accommodation for them to live in
obviously some of the pressures around
tier four so those young people that are
in hospital and need to have a step out
step down provision it's a really
difficult complex Market you know to
find suitable accommodation for those
young people and again they tend to be
our high cost provision
ability to provide range and choice for
our children young people instead
production and Care in foster care is
both internally and externally that
impacts on having the right choice of
provision placements and matches for our
children young people
as I've said reduction the number of
internal Foster carers which were
working a project for to to improve that
and you obviously want to have more
availability and choice for our CAD
experience young people so when they do
step out of being cared for at 16 or
since 16 18 that we've got the right
suitable placements and provision for
them to move on into
so again how we're going to address
those challenges on both in the short
term and long term but you know one of
the main priorities of returning the
fostering service back to growth so
we've got you know discuss previous
we've got a modernization plan which
we're working through with the view that
we will increase the number of of foster
care but also really important it will
retain our current Foster Care Community
as well within that we've got the
greater Manchester projects a number of
project streams within greater
Manchester at the moment you know
particularly around fostering around and
we'll have a live recruitment campaign
um in May so that's been agreed in the
last couple of days
we're working
um we're for um other local parties to
have some soft block arrangements for
residential homes so we have a choice
when we need um placements for children
young people
we've got a new um Innovative project
Skyline which is again working across
gray to Manchester in terms of having
more residential sufficiency for all 10
greater Manchester local authorities we
very much would want a you know a focus
on again those young people in hospital
tier four admissions so you know we've
got suitable accommodation if and when
they need to be discharged back into the
community got the no wrong door relaunch
which we're working through at the
moment um with hopefully a live date
later in the spring
and we've got the Trafford housing
project which we talked about previously
we've got seven young people currently
engaged in that so that's that's really
fantastic and we're just in the process
of identifying our cohort too ready to
go live in September
I think it's in summer I think you know
even with all the previous um success
we've had in terms of making
year-on-year savings we're getting to a
point now it's going to be really
challenging for us to make any further
um savings within the budgets that we've
been set but given the complexity of our
children young people
we know for nature of children's social
care work is unpredictable so we know as
we talked about which one we would want
to offset any new admissions with
existing young people but it's very
difficult we don't know what's coming
through in terms of complexity and
sufficiency remains difficulty both
nationally and locally and within
Trafford and but we've got lots of
things that we're trying to do to to
address that so I'm hoping that's a bit
of a whistle top it was great thank you
for the report
um
clearly there's a lot
of data to analyze in there does anybody
have any questions
could I ask you acronym pnw
so BMW and placements North West so
that's all 20 okay
um plus Local 23 thank you local
authorities that have signed up to
placements Northwest
no no so they might they managed the um
the framework that we use in terms of
identifying residential and fostering
placements
um do you think there'll be a sort of
cut off when we don't get any more sgos
I think what I'd say is we're in a
position where we've got a number of
special guarantee borders that need to
be made and part of the work we do
around the permanent strategy and I've
just developed and set up a permanence
panel um in Trafford so actually let's
say there's a high number of
um young people we've identified that
actually special guarantee board is the
right approach over the next 12 18 yes
oh God yeah and just you you obviously
mentioned the um the relaunch of the uh
no wrong law and he said it's sort of
late spring yeah
um what what will that involve so I
think I think what what's been difficult
is um around recruitment to some of the
key positions so um as part of the
redesign that you know did finish um
last year and there was a number of
specialist posts that we identified when
we're competing with five or six other
local authorities within greater
Manchester for the same positions we
found it extremely um difficult to
recruit to a number of specialist posts
with one post away from both specialist
posts being
um being can we can we not train people
up to those one of the one of the roles
that we thought we had successfully
recruited to is
um what's called the life coach so a
trained qualified clinical psychologist
to work in and through the children's
home
um unfortunately they've decided to stay
in their their current position so it
it's not a question of can we just
upscale and train people they are very
specialist roles to make that offer look
different to maximize the preventative
element of it yeah and just lastly
um there's you you've allocated
um you know monies for the numbers of
children we've currently got and then
you're saying if we get more we've then
got to jiggle around with what's the
pots of money that you've got left so
two things
um we have benefited from some
investment in terms of the medium-term
financial plan in recognition of the
cost pressures that are being driven by
the market not in terms of all of the
work that we're doing either on a
preventative basis or in order to
successfully manage and support young
people to step down or live in the most
appropriate
um areas the other thing that we have
done is to untangle some of the budget
aspects so preview obviously if somebody
was in foster care moved into
residential and then moved back into
foster care the funding would follow
them what we've worked with our finance
colleagues is to fix the budget so that
we can see exactly with transparency
where those budget pressures all right
um because actually it's the type of
placement and placement availability
that's driving the cost pressures
upwards and I hope you got a flavor of
that from the slides I think what the
service has demonstrated is that we've
had a really strong track record in
terms of making the Savings in terms of
reducing our numbers of looks after
children
but if there isn't placement
availability then we are ending up with
some of those real high cost placements
and we are seeing an increase in
complexity of our young people yeah
um I understand all your challenges and
I thank I thank you all for for what you
do for the young people and children in
Trafford thank you
does anybody else have any questions no
can I just say that was a very
impressive and very impressive
presentation and I just think that you
clearly have a strong grasp of your
brief
absolutely thank you it then it's not
down to me it's down to the guys that
work with it unless we acknowledge
appreciate the papers were late so if
there are detailed questions that people
want to come back on if we need to
agenda it for for this scrutiny in the
the new Municipal year they're more than
happy to but I think that is one of the
things that we have really brought in
terms of that monitoring that focus and
that drive linked to some of the things
we brought previously on culture change
behind every one of those numbers is a
child or a young person and it's really
important that just like you did earlier
that we understand their stories and
their histories
thanks Jill and thanks to all of you um
for coming this evening and forth to
physically in-depth reports and I'm
going to move on I can see time is
sticking on
um
given the
um Pamela mentioned the emotional mental
health issues that children are having
um which drove us really something I've
been interested in for a long time
um into
um
becomes the Children's Mental Health
obviously the the number of referrals
particularly post pandemic which has
affected children from early years right
through to University so we did form a
task and finish group this year we've
had slightly delays due to by-election
and pre-election and one thing and
another we have met with
um two of the providers
um which have
um really helpful
um information gathering so we have got
another meeting scheduled
um in the next couple of weeks to try
and get some feedback from service users
and then I'm hoping that in some at some
point
um we'll be able to put together some
recommendations
um which will go to the executive so
perhaps we're probably two maybe three
meetings off collating all that
information but I'm hoping to do that
before
um
the end of not in the municipal year but
certainly
um before the end of the pre-election
period
and
then last item on the Gen the agenda is
topics for consideration in next
Municipal year now I don't know
um if I will still be sharing it but
Alex made a suggestion as it came in
that at some point we make contacts
again with those fantastic students and
ask them
to give us suggestions of
what they would like us to discuss
what's important to them do you think
that's a good idea it's all about these
youngsters that are coming up and
everything we do impacts on them so
you might be scrutinized more than you
used to but I've never met such a bunch
of inspirational young people the best
questions always come from our young
people don't absolutely yeah and that's
what that's what we're all about
so with that I'm going to close the
meeting I'm not aware of any urgent
business
um and thank you all for attending I'm
sorry enough catch you a bit later than
normal but um
I just think it's so important it is my
favorite meeting of the year when we
actually have the young people in with
us
safe journey home everybody